Congress is now on recess for the
holidays giving Democrats and
Republicans to four weeks to consider
the next steps in the impeachment
showdown 60 minutes correspondent John
Dickerson is here okay
Congress okay Nancy Pelosi has said
she's not gonna send the articles of
impeachment over to the Senate we don't
know when she will right what's the game
plan at the moment she's not gonna do it
I think the game plan is essentially a
process argument on the Democratic side
we've heard Republicans making process
arguments in the house
well Democrats are trying to shape the
process in the Senate and if they can't
actually shape it and get rules
favorable to their side they want to at
least put it in a context and argue
basically that Republican leader
McConnell is not allowing a fair trial
so that at least when the president is
acquitted in the Senate as everyone
expects it at least has that context
that the Democrats get but the downside
for Nancy Pelosi is people say wait a
minute
you've gone through this process it's
not very serious if you're not sending
over the artist McConnell made a pretty
good point where he said you're not
there's no leverage in not sending us
the thing we don't want question though
that maybe so here's the alternative
case the president despite what his
daughter says is steamed about this and
he's out there showing that and that
puts some pressure on Mitch McConnell to
get this thing rolling and get that
acquittal happening so I'm not sure that
there's no leverage it may not be a huge
amount of it but there is other things
at play here and that that other thing
at play is the president who wants John
there was a very interesting op-ed in
Christianity today which called for the
president Trump to be removed in
basically endorsed impeachment in very
strong language how significant is this
well this is I don't know that it's
gonna change any evangelical minds but
this comes from within the president's
base and and and the argument is twofold
one is that the president is is immoral
I mean and that he behaves in a way that
is unchristian but then the other thing
that's extraordinary about this
editorial is it says that evangelicals
are breaking their Christian witness if
they support the president's puts
pressure on those evangelical the
language let me just none of the
president's positives can balance the
more impolitic moral and political
danger we face under a
leader of such grossly immoral character
Wow this is this is his base it is to
space and also there is a gulf that you
see you see this editorial and and
compare it to what you're hearing from
the president Republicans which is the
president has done nothing wrong
this was a perfect relationship with
Ukraine in office he has been perfect
and yet now you have from within his
base saying not only has he broken with
his oath of office but he breaks with
the codes that are the highest and most
important codes of the way we live our
lives that's a real difference in the
way you look at this and it's a it's
it's a challenge for the president he
can no longer I mean say basically
there's nothing to any of this when
they're talking about the most important
questions in life that go directly to
the creator and jump over politics and
as strong as that language is there's
nothing to indicate that his base is
eroding is there no and particularly
among evangelicals which and he's been
arguing basically an attack on me is an
attack on you which as political as a
political defense is a smart one for him
all right John Dickerson always good to
see you
you